Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
It has been a week for Marvel.
There were a bunch of huge announcements
this week about the future of Doctor Doom,
Avengers five Avengers, six secret wars,
what they're going to do with Jonathan Majors.
Kang is the overarching main villain
and they confirm plans to bring back
Iron Man
and all the original Avengers, even Black Widow.
It was a lot like, seriously, there were like ten
different big announcements all at the same time.
Having a big audience for you must be a cool thing.
Good for you.
You made it in Seattle cause,
you know, fingers crossed.
we'll break it all down.
Some of that just confirms
what we already knew. Like some of this stuff.
I've actually already done videos
about the past couple of months,
but there were a few big surprises.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing, the Loki Blu-Ray giveaways.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just post all your theories
about how you want them to introduce Doctor
Doom in the MCU.
starting with probably the biggest announcement
in all of this stuff.
Doctor Doom himself Variety.
The other major trades confirmed that
Kevin Feige and Marvel
are about to completely get rid of Jonathan Majors.
Kang the Conqueror in the whole concept of
the Council of Kangs is an overarching villain,
way faster in favor of pivoting to Doctor
Doom Apparently they're right on the cusp
of making him the main overarching villain
in Avengers six Secret wars.
if you're not a big comic book fan
or you haven't read the more recent
comic book Secret Wars, it is nuts.
I would recommend checking it out because they
will be basing at least some of Avengers six on it.
then making doctor Doom
the main villain would be like Marvel
doing a more comic book
accurate version of that more recent Secret Wars.
It would be God Emperor Doom
being the main villain on Battle World.
we've already been hearing how they're going
to involve the TVA, and there's going to be
a version of Battle World during Deadpool
three in that's meant to set up secret wars.
So all this seems like it's just heading towards
a more comic book accurate version of Secret Wars.
here's the thing, though. People are like what?
They're getting rid of Jonathan Majors.
Nothing has been confirmed about them
getting rid of him yet.
supposedly that's going to be answered
by the end of Loki season two.
Like they'll be a clear point
at the end of Loki Season two.
That will explain what the future of Jonathan
Majors Kang or the Council of Kangs is going to be.
in. Apparently Marvel talked about pivoting to Doctor
Doom from King
like it's a whole concept of the Council of Kangs
right after Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania
disappointed at the box office earlier this year.
it sounds like they might have panicked
a little bit,
like the general public
who aren't big comic book fans.
Like all the casuals, the larger families out there
wouldn't be quite as down for like
the Council of Kangs versus the Avengers
or more Kangs beyond that, in Secret Wars,
as your average comic book reader who's
just way more familiar with King as a character.
so, at least initially earlier
this year, Marvel pivoting away from Jonathan
Majors,
Kang had nothing to do with his legal troubles.
That didn't happen till later in the year.
the way the variety
the other trades were reporting it, that Marvel
had their big yearly retreat out in Palm Springs.
The powers that be, Kevin Feige
all met to discuss what they're going to do
with the future of Marvel movies and shows.
That's where they talked about bringing back
the original Avengers, Iron Man,
Black Widow, pivoting to Doctor Doom
as the main overarching villain.
Then much later after that retreat, like later
in the year, Jonathan Majors started
having his legal troubles.
That sort of compounded Marvel's desire
to generally just move
past Kang as a character, like he was starting
to become more trouble than it was worth to them
when they had so many other major
A-list characters in their toy chest on tap
that they could just roll out
is like another big Avengers level villain.
this also kind of confirms why you haven't seen
more Doctor Doom Easter eggs in the MCU movies.
Are the TV shows up to this point?
Why they didn't reference him back
during Black Panther was kind of forever.
they were going to start seeding
the idea that he was looking for vibranium
and then use the adamantium storyline
in Captain America four
and just like seed him in the background
so that he became a much bigger villain
and they introduced more of his technology
side and his magical side during the doctor.
Strange side of things.
Doctor Doom is one of those really interesting
characters in that he's really big.
People really familiar with him,
but he's a man of science and a man of technology,
so he works well in technology base stories
like Iron Man type of movies,
but he also works really well in magic based movies
like the really darker supernatural stuff.
see, you can use him in pretty much
any kind of movie and he'll work really well.
I did a couple videos about this
when they were getting ready to release
Black Panther, broken up forever.
But Lake Bell's character, for instance,
at the beginning of that movie was supposed to be
Lucia von BARDA from a lot Barry, inside the MCU.
they were also supposed to reference a lot
very during Moonlight, for example, like the castle
that we see is meant to be a representation
of a castle in the Doctor Doom Comics.
see, you can kind of see that at a certain point
they were starting to see the character
and then they decided to maybe
pivot to the character, like,
maybe we actually make him
the next Avengers villain.
So they changed a bunch of their plans.
as far as I know, they didn't get as far along
as actually casting an actor to play the character.
They made a lot of rumors about who might wind up
playing him in Marvel, as far as I know,
hasn't revealed yet
whether they're actually going to swap
a Kang version of the Beyond
or in Secret orders for God Emperor Doom.
Like will they actually make him
the next overarching villain?
all the variety the trades we're reporting is
that Marvel had like really serious discussions
about like, okay,
if we're going to pivot away from Jonathan Majors,
this is probably
who the next villain is going to be.
We do know that Doctor Doom
isn't going to be a major character
in the new Fantastic Four movie
that they're going to release in a couple of years.
Galactus
is supposed to be the main villain of that,
and at least before all the gods
Emperor Doom Secret Wars talk.
Marvel was planning on introducing the character
in a totally different non Fantastic Four movie.
But if you think about it, if Marvel wants him
to be an impactful main villain in secret wars
like in a big Avengers movie, they had developed
the character significantly before.
They just rule him out
like they can't just show up in secret wars
and be like, Ha ha, I'm behind everything.
really good example
that is Loki in the first Avengers movie.
Like he was the main
villain in the first Avengers movie,
but before that they introduced him in
the first Thor movie and he was a main character.
They developed the character
pretty well during that.
so that by the time you get to the first Avengers
movie, you know who he is when he shows up.
I'm burdened with glorious purpose.
they basically have to do kind of the same thing
for Doctor Doom
Ensigns Kevin Feige and Marvel
have control of like 99% of their characters.
Now, my current idea
for how they introduced the Doctor Doom character
is they introduce him at the end of the Iron Man
Armor Wars movie, and to say that he was the one
that was really trying to get his hands
on all the stark tech in all the adamantium
that they're going to introduce in Captain America
four just say he was behind it.
Like he's not a main character in those movies.
It just shows up in like the post-credits scenes
or just some teasers, just saying that he wants
all that technology, all that new adamantium
to enhance his own armor, his own weapons,
maybe other few cameo scenes in other Marvel movies
during Marvel Phase six.
Then they use him as one of the major characters
in Doctor Strange three
as a way to show off his magical power.
And because Doctor Strange three is so focused
on all of the incursions storyline
that was a major part of the lead up to comic book
Secret Wars in the Time runs out storyline.
if you didn't read that original version of Secret
Wars, Doctor Doom
was revealed to be a major player
during that storyline.
So using him in Doctor Strange
three would just be another more comic book
accurate version of this storyline.
then you have Doctor Doom fighting with the heroes
during Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
against the Council of Kangs Then
at the end of that movie he winds up being the one
to kill the remaining Council of Kangs
and tries to seize control of all reality himself.
And it's another comic book moment just swapping
the billionaires for the Council of Kangs
during the lead up to comic book Secret Wars,
he stole the power of the billionaires
to become God, Emperor of Doom
and save what was left of all.
Reality is
the remaining universe has started collapsing.
We're kind of seeing that play out in the MCU
right now with the incursions.
The Marvel's movie is coming out next week.
As I'm posting this video, we're going to see
an incursion going down during that movie.
Doctor Doom combined the fragments of all
the surviving universes into a single battle world
where a bunch of the multiverse characters
who survive from these other universes all lived.
But when he did that, he also changed the timeline.
We're talking about Loki Easter eggs
here changed reality to what he wanted it to be.
so in this new version of reality that he created
on Battle World, he was with Sue Storm,
who loved him
and he'd always been in love with this whole time.
Everyone's served him, worshiped him as God.
Emperor Doom Eventually the survivors
figured out what really happened,
banded together and stopped him,
then restored the multiverse.
So it does sound like Marvel might wind up doing
a more comic book accurate version of Secret Wars.
Would they do wind up doing
will be a little bit different though.
Like we still know that Tobey Maguire and Hugh
Jackman will be like the main leads
of that movie Spider-Man Wolverine in They'll be
a multiverse version of the Avengers team.
The Doctor Strange puts together.
Kevin Feige is still going to use the movie
as a sort of a swansong for all the legacy
Fox Marvel actors.
Like give them their own version
of Avengers Endgame
but it just sounds like they might wind up
swapping Doctor
Doom for Kang I think a lot of people
would actually prefer that to a lot of people
when they announce Secret Wars were like, Yay,
do God emperor doom would be amazing.
It would be the simplest thing in the world.
Does this have him show up at the end of Avengers
five and just swipe
the rest of the Council of Kangs
and try to take control of all reality himself?
you just have to develop the character enough
before Avengers five.
here's
where we get to the other Avengers coming back.
So the next big announcement
that they made this week
was they confirmed that Marvel was going
to bring back all of the original Avengers,
including Iron Man and Black Widow,
who died during Avengers Endgame.
We always knew that
they were going to come back, though.
I think the only difference is
they just confirmed it and we know now
what's changed
is they'll probably ask for way more money.
think about how much Robert Downey
Jr is going to get paid for this.
Supposedly
Loki Season two is going to end on a moment
that will explain a little bit more about Marvel's
path forward towards Avengers five.
now, a lot of you are asking
how does this affect Marvel's reboot
that they're supposed to be using secret wars for?
Like they're going to use secret wars
to do a soft reboot of the Marvel Universe
and make it look more like the true comic book?
616 Universe going forward.
Generally,
I don't think this changes anything about that.
Like Kevin Feige, he's always going to retune
things behind the scenes with Secret Wars.
Generally, it does seem like Kevin Feige
is starting to get a handle on writing the course,
like righting the ship at Marvel,
like things are heading in a much better direction.
summer, even though it does seem like
things are really crazy over there right now,
I think like in the next couple of years
they'll get things worked out for the most part,
there is a backlog of stuff
that they've already made during
their more chaotic like during the pandemic period
that they still have to release.
so it'll probably be a little while before
we actually get to like the brand new projects
that they've completely reworked
from the ground up.
Really good example that is Daredevil Born again,
like they completely canceled the previous version,
the show they hired on the showrunner
from The Punisher, a bunch of the Loki people,
a bunch of the Moon Knight people
to make a much better version of the show in it
sounds like Kevin Feige is just doing that for
like all the upcoming Marvel movies and TV shows.
Like he's just making better versions
of all that stuff.
there are a couple really big things
that are coming up that do seem that
they're going to be bangers, though,
like X-Men 97 is coming up early next year.
There are a couple other big projects
that I'll talk about.
We get some trailers,
I we're also supposed to get an echo trailer
probably Friday morning, maybe next week
whenever they release it.
Of course I'll do a video for it.
It's going to be a big daredevil
and kingpin reunion in the MCU,
I know there's a billion other questions
that everybody has about all the upcoming stuff,
like all these Marvel announcements
just raise more questions than they answer.
So whatever they wind up
announcing in the next couple of weeks,
of course, they'll do videos for that.
my full Loki Season
two Episode five Video We'll post next.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
My Invincible Season
two Episode one video We'll post after that too.
There's also a boys
Gen V finale coming out this week to
I will try to post all that stuff
as quickly as possible.
Click here for that Loki Season
two episode five Video
and click here to learn about that
big Marvel reboot that's happening.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!